what are your thoughts on ce5 so it's a
method of oh i know what it is
yeah okay yeah yeah
um okay so i do know that people i know
people who do it and i know that um
people say oh i've had success with it
but i mean i wouldn't be doing it
i don't exactly insane i feel the same
you know
i feel like it's playing with it's such
a
it's such an unknown with such a drastic
consequence that it's it's worse than
playing with fire
yeah i'm not gonna do it
i'm not gonna do it
well forget about whether or not you're
gonna do it what have you heard about it
is there efficacy to it what occurs
during it
yeah so i i have heard a lot of people
say that they have you know initiated
contact through the methods of ce5
um
i've had people ask me to do it with
them right and be in communities of
people who do it i stay away from that
no i'm not gonna do that now why do i
say that because
uh well for one thing
a lot you know
learning about religious traditions you
do learn there's a lot of things that
actually happen and you don't know why
okay and so i already believe that
certain things can happen
i don't really need to have up close
knowledge of this and nor do i think
that we can predict the consequences
so i guess that's my point is that yeah
i do believe that these kinds of things
work but just like we had you know just
like we talked about with the woo
science you know
that
just because people are doing it and
getting these effects
doesn't mean that the story they're
telling themselves and each other about
it is true
so i guess that's how i feel about it is
we're not certain about it why do it
and plus i've had also another thing is
that i've had so many people ask me to
do it and they were almost like
they wanted me to do it so badly that i
thought i don't really want to do this
because they're asking me you know they
really so much want me to do it i surely
don't want to do it now
why is that the case because you feel
like it's peer pressure and there's
something wrong about it like drugs or
why is it the case that if they're
putting so much pressure on you you
don't want to do it
yeah because i feel like you know if
somebody's so invested in me doing it
that
either they're getting something from it
or
they're you know i really don't know i'm
suspicious it just sets off alarms and
i'm not quite sure what those alarms are
but no way i wouldn't do it anyway but
especially when people really want you
to do it